I'm a little late to watching the Xbox
Bethesda showcase today because I
couldn't do it this morning I can now so
here we are I'm gonna avoid reading chat
it's a little because I really don't
have anything spoiled for me there are
some things that I would really like to
see obviously you all know that I'm a
huge Fable fan I was saying literally to
Phil Spencer last night
that
um I only want to see Fable if it's soon
like I'd love to see gameplay
but not if it's too far away I always
love to see new Forza Horizon content
I'm curious about Perfect Dark obviously
also a very big Perfect Dark fan
um and obviously also I don't know how
many times I've already said obviously
also excuse my voice I'm sick
half of this so let's just do it let's
go
tell me if the audio is okay when it
kicks in
I don't know why I feel like I'm nervous
[Music]
so hoping for fable and for it to be
close by that I'm nervous
oh we're finally doing this really
because I was gonna make a sandwich
oh my God they're doing it straight away
oh my God
and it's small to do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes
well we've all seen them haven't we
swanning about the place
with their disproportionately high
cheekbones and Comics
oh my God because they like to rough up
Bandits don't they living it up with the
common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the true
heroes me someone who's breaking you
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things this is very
just smart casting not wafting around I
guess he might just beat the trailer
though
that's what they are what you chase
chickens
you see I'm not here to slay legendary
beasts
conquer the vegetable not a euphemism
let's face it the age of Heroes is over
this is the age of innovation this if
you will is the age of death I have
Goosebumps everybody I have Goosebumps
one moment
this is awkward
yeah
[Music]
does that mean he's a boss
oh my gosh
it looks so different but of course it
does it's been a long time oh
[Music]
are you just gonna stand there like a
lemon
when
but when
nothing
[Music]
okay look tonally perfect
but I have so many questions
oh I'm wondering what compulsion's been
working on oh my god dude oh ah
okay okay
I guess that wasn't gameplay and it's
probably still pretty pretty far away
shaking bones
it's been a while
[Music]
so you remember that favor you owe me
oh he's also a giant not a good giant
content
[Music]
these black knives
no
all right how about you guys
no what's the weather
this is a the style is beautiful it's so
unique I don't think I've ever played a
game that looks like this
[Applause]
sneaky
[Music]
[Applause]
south of midnight okay but another
cinematic trailer so we don't know too
much
good night
does look very unique though
World premiere yeah where was he the
first time you can't have to you can't
not have the world premiere Guy come on
dangerous times
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
s
is always once at least one Star Wars
every time
is the audio okay can you let me know
real quick I'm trying not to look at the
chat too much sorry
good okay thank you I want to survive
I have to play their game
so cute
so this is ub's first
star war and I wonder why they're doing
it here I'm not up there
money I guess
I'm out
there she is
again beautiful but another cinematic
trailer
[Music]
it's been held back my whole life
and now
it's something like this is like very
roguish like you got to make it stand
out from
from Survivor huh wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me it'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again this is like graphically stunning
but I guess I want to be so cinematic to
those off like this looks beautiful big
fan of the little fuzzy
what do they call axolotl
the underworld shows no mercy
[Music]
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it all I just feel like it
looks uh
[Music]
well maybe if there are other dog farts
I have so many questions Stop Those
Outlaws but isn't the Jedi survival of
bowling order franchise basically
Outlaws
I'm a little bit confused by that one
okay great okay we'll watch that and
then I'll have my answers
he's like is that not like just they
competing with each other half of
Midnight Star Wars Outlaws Welcome to
our first ever double feature the Xbox
game showcase followed by a deep dive
into one of the most important RPG Jedi
stuff that I don't feel like that's
gonna necessarily make it different
enough I don't know
presenting is hard
it's also not her job
[Music]
World premiere
she does a great job
[Music]
it's giving Hades
foreign
[Music]
probably would have been my only night
but it is weird sometimes you don't know
what to do with your hands I clasp mine
I always have my hands folded in my
stomach
[Music]
pick up and raid multiplayer oh that's
neat
[Music]
it's like well I'm sorry what oh my God
I really thought it was gonna be four
[__] did you just say 33
oh my god
um it's like it's sort of like uh Hades
Diablo
33 player co-op okay I was like because
I was like how is this standing out
obviously it looks very pretty I don't
doubt the music will be beautiful
Spirit fair is a stunning game but then
you slept 33 play a co-op on me oh my
God
[Music]
33 Immortals that's really cool
damn how awesome
all right guys it's a simple job
just standing out nothing to it
[Music]
okay it's a heist game
oh is it payday everybody hit the floor
I like I was gonna be like oh it looks
like payday but it might actually be
payday I don't think you can fake that
it's payday 3.
[Music]
It's gotta it's got it otherwise yikes
I mean this looks like
way smoother
than payday 2.
obviously more visually impressive I
play Payday in a minute
it looks still looks uh
older than the other games that have
been part of this conference but I think
that's it's something cool
damn
does that mean it's an XBox exclusive
hmm
payday's good fun everybody it really is
[Music]
World premiere
I didn't expect to see Atlas hello
[Music]
this is P3
oh I did actually see these rumors
to understand again now I'm ready for
the reasons
so wait because it's it's P3
coming to
Game Pass probably
[Music]
reload because it looks it did I was
like it does look a little bit different
ah
I wonder what that means it's okay I'm a
big Persona person
it's like
it didn't even look like P3 to me
originally but I was like that's those
characters so they're like fully
ground up remake I wonder if they'll
change dungeons
that's like super exciting I knew that
was something to do with Persona that
got leaked I didn't know exactly what it
was
to him
that's really cool
Assassin's Creed
it doesn't look like Mirage obsidian
it's about people don't like you very
much do they
[Music]
sent here to the living lands
by an emperor who couldn't bother to
come himself
to investigate some plague
really excited about this game
[Music]
you want us to trust you
but the truth is
you scare us
the way you fight
it'd be so cool if this game had be off
compatibility in some capacity
environment's really nice yeah
it's here's the thing about obsidian
it's like
they make great games like no matter
what games
I think I would prefer it to be fully
third person and I'm unclear if it is
based on this I think it's fun
which makes sense
I love planting
what are you gonna do with it
it's like I just have no doubt that this
game will be good
release date
who is that who's there
okay
keeping it big I respect it
dizzy has already got enough video games
I don't even need more of them this year
give them to me next year good stuff
getting kind of an idea of a timeline
sea thieves
oh
it is the Sea of Thieves okay
uh you have not missed stopfield that's
at the end actually because of the time
I will probably have to stop Starfield
so I can go to the Final Fantasy 16
event and then come back and do the stop
build reaction it is Monkey Island yeah
that's awesome that's such a good
crossover
[Music]
welcome to the scum bar the most
notorious Tavern it's such a good idea
[Music]
ship is right for you A big ship a
luxury ship a ship with just a splash of
je ne sais quoi I wonder if Dominic is
in it you mean Governor guybrush but
freeport's nuts he's gonna be in it oh
Dominic is the voice actor who plays
never stupid hey I did a podcast I told
you no autographs
though I see you have a meet and greet
ticket that rules it's not every day
that you get to meet the mighty pirate
guy Rush 3 wood the legend of Monkey
Island
amazing this is such a good idea
is up this island into a prison for guys
such a spot
collaboration well
[Music]
we'll need these
things such a good idea let's promise
I'm so sorry I [__] love sea of
Thieves
like I I don't think I've ever played
sea of Thieves and not had an incredible
time like it's
amazing great job Gigi red whoa awesome
that rules
see if monkey indeed indeed World
premiere World premiere yeah they're
killing it with the pacing we are back
to back to back to back here
but whom but humps
[Music]
what does that mean
it's just an update
I imagine
[Music]
oh cool
oh it's like job stuff that's deep I
assume it's still in Microsoft flight
simulator it's just like an expansion
thank you
[Music]
sweet I am so bad at flight Sims
um truly terrible
uh and I respect the hell out of
Microsoft flight simulator
I will not play this
again assuming it's an expansion not a
new game
but it is beautiful
and like super technically impressive
though I guess this could give me like
the same
like with more
focus on tasks this could maybe have the
same effect on me that like power washed
simulator is
[Music]
nice okay that's pretty sick
the look on his face you smug cellular
whoa cool
oh yeah that's top down right there
[Music]
I still don't know if it's an expansion
or a new game
new game
I guess it's a new Microsoft flight
simulator Molina here speaking to you
from our performance capture stage let's
go just wrapped our shoots for sanwa
Saga hellblade 2. when we first showed
gameplay for hellblade 2 it was a look
at some of the games cinematic and
immersive action where senua faced off
against a gigantic troll on the
Icelandic Coastline I was like was that
a car in the background are they
recording
a personal Quest her unique perspective
on the world and I mean that awaits you
in senua Saga
what you'll see today is all captured by
the team on Xbox series X
amazing let's do it let's do it
love Ninja Theory
I might replay the first one
gotta do it with
surround sound headphones following the
threats of her mind
is here to find them
she needs her help with a promise
when it's never so simple is it
so good wisdom has a prize
there's always a part of you then Chase
it's just so Eerie dude
uh the first one's pretty short you
could finish it in probably like
I'd say like five to seven hours
they are watching us
an animation to help it y'all just kill
it
it's time to find out what are they
waiting for
are you waiting for I'm here
she's watching more than one
where are they where are you what do
they want I don't mind
their eyes
feel them boring
[Music]
this is obviously much more auditorily
interesting than visually not that it's
not visually too but like I feel like
that's so rare in trailers
I just want to listen to it
what if it's all for nothing
[Music]
this is very cool
here
one two two
I'm so glad that I have headphones that
have fun
[Music]
Surround Sound audio
parts of here that are broken you can be
whole
all the grave all the rage
everything I've seen
I've seen
everything I've done
has led me to this place we've come so
far not far enough this is really
surreal man tell them
I am here
now what if we get lost forever
what will happen to them what will
happen to you
I will not let them down she is ready
[Music]
okay
who are these around you sir I just
don't think a trailer has had like that
effect on me before
next year okay I was hoping that would
be this year but it's okay it's okay
it's okay
um
yeah that's very intense uh
was already sold on Hellboy two the
gameplay from the Lost Trail looked
[__] phenomenal so
what up like a dragon
[Music]
it's a dead or alive
Yakuza Edition and I would play it
all right okay
yeah okay
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
oh surf's up dude yeah dude
[Music]
he just did
so like a dragon Yakuza series is like
no other the fact that they get away
with stuff like this and they nail it
and it's so funny
Korea
[Music]
amazing
um no I'm not watching infinite wealth
they've announced two games the past few
days haven't they
okay
amazing um I'm not watching the Final
Fantasy 16 event I'm actually hosting
the Final Fantasy 16 event so as soon as
I'm done watching this I will go and
watch that okay
I will go to that I mean and you'll see
my face on that stream
but no I was already there doing a tech
rehearsal and everything yesterday
Fallout
is it Reclamation
from the heart of Western thanks for the
raid kind of funny hello everyone I'm
catching up on the Xbox conference no
spoilers I have not seen it yet I was
not able to watch it this morning please
no spoil's friends
uh lost my mind about fables
such a good choice
our world is all it is all changing
which I had a great time with and has
improved significantly like this game
has had a comeback
settlements to Nuka World on tour you're
never short on things to do or places
you just feel like the choice to Launch
well how about without
voiced NPCs
put your rad shield on and fix your hair
up pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City so this is a
DLC for Fallout 26 I'm guessing now you
know there's a million ways to make the
Wasteland your way such and when you
hear it distinctive and iconic marketing
for Fallout
answer the call a vault
[Music]
answer the call of all 76.
nice you always know exactly what it is
oh that's a good touch oh it's available
now
oh
well that's a bit confusing
World premiere
Capcom at it again boys
[Music]
I said what I said about Capcom
they killing it doing a great job right
now
it could be animation
I'm not sure
[Music]
okay
how weird which I love
damn
it's kind of freaky
dude this is so weird looking I love it
foreign
beautiful animation
I feel like it's been a really long time
since we've had the third person action
game with the camera that far out as
well I kind of miss it like I have like
a weird nostalgia
it's mola protagonist
path of the goddess
that looks sick
what the heck
Capcom I said what I said they are
killing it right now
credit what credit is due dude
and new IP and it was gameplay that was
awesome
wow General this has been amazing so far
to Performance is embodied in two of its
photonic brands
Chevrolet and Cadillac
the V series dot R elevates Cadillac's
competitive Spirit I'm not a motorsport
person anymore and Hybrid Power
um I used to play some racing Sims I
don't anymore the legendary has been a
celebrated Champion for decades
the all-new Chevrolet Corvette they're
always you can use that tradition such a
benchmark
General Motors is proud
it's always a visual Delight protection
innovators behind the new Forza
Motorsport Ford sound Motorsport
s of Motorsport and General Motors are
pairing their strengths and Technical
excellence and sophisticated dude I saw
this to take sorry to talk numbers into
the future and bring that experience I
saw this gameplay of Moto GP the other
day welcome the cadillacv series dot r
that I didn't know was gameplay I
assumed it was actual footage of the
Isle of Man race
[Applause]
um and it wasn't it's the first time in
my life that I've been fooled by
gameplay footage and I really was like
oh this is Isle of Man
GoPro footage I know you're ready
because I've watched a fair amount of
Isle of Man
no purpose because it's fascinating
it was just
MotoGP it was crazy for the next one
is that Cortana
[Music]
yeah racing Sims are always a benchmark
for like where we're at rapidly I think
foreign
Man TT but that's the question I
couldn't believe it was a game like
it was unbelievable
it was your best lap yet
gt70 is unbelievable I've heard that I
haven't tried it yet I gotta try it
[Music]
foreign
new expansion I'm guessing
sci-fi looking thing
or perhaps the first time in my unending
with high fee
disconnected from face flow
against
hidden
loving this to the
oddsm in a pretty long time
always get why it's part of these
conferences always get words here
the people I know who play it are
extremely into it
and I did when it came to console
actually it might have been the
five-star MMI platon console
but I have this um
real issue with MMOs where I kind of
can't play them because they really
ruined my life
um my favorites uh Guild Wars flashlight
was too and I loved Neverwinter
and obviously quite a bit of a while but
um if I start I can't stop I won't sleep
I won't eat
Gabrielle I cannot play
MMOs I'm even having that problem with
Diablo right now thankfully the all this
conference stuff has meant that I can't
play it
ugh cool uh but yeah I just can't
play on this unit 37. Toronto is under
attack
I know sector Valor something different
about no sector this time oh I've
watched they've taken over most of the
city and they're rounding up omnics they
need our help
I guess
and we have so much to teach them
then they just cancel a bunch of content
sector maybe we can save the city coming
through
as if I didn't have enough problems
already
what is this
upstairs smash through anything that
gets in our way
and what's another business I hate to
interrupt the moment but I'm picking up
reports of more attacks in other cities
so maybe this is their replacement for
the canceled Easter
okay yeah it's just a few gamers
well I guess at least they did something
[Applause]
just a real weird one with OverWatch man
like
I really feel like overwatched two
shouldn't have come out
it really should have just been you
OverWatch content
[Music]
yeah okay
[Applause]
how's he doing though like I wonder what
what are the play counts
[Music]
trace's ass though you know what I'm
saying
that came across like it's a new trailer
for OverWatch
let's go shall we do this together it's
likely it was so hot dude
okay
World premiere
world's premiere
again more Atlas
what are you doing to me here what is
this place
what the hell is going on it's chippy P5
attack
you get us out of here so you're telling
me your thieves who steal hearts and you
just happen to stumble into this world
Persona fans
[Music]
doing great today
oh my God it's so cute
what's your test
[Music]
unfortunately oh my God
somewhere deep inside I know you realize
things can't go on like this so will you
take a stand I mean it's I'm just so
happy that like personas come to Xbox
now too
back
Sona 5 tacticup p5t okay cool
looks cute big fan of P5
great cool with it more excited about
the P3 remake that's very exciting but
this is still cool
I'd love to be the world premiered voice
of a person
World premiere Humanity has always
hunted for knowledge Humanity
is this stuff field already I'm
wondering I'm not ready for that yet not
that the field of stars is so vast we
haven't start is this this is William
the Starfield director
[Music]
sneak peek okay good okay okay okay
because I'm not gonna watch that part
we're gonna watch it later
[Music]
are you weird for being turned off by
the size of this game no because I'm
right there with you
it's such a weird concern to have but it
is my biggest concern
is that uh 25 years in the making damn
oh we're all here because we're
committed to the biggest question I like
I hate the marketing term bigger and
better I like bigger I don't like bigger
I like better
whoa
[Music]
you're part of constellation now
part of our family hey I'm really
excited about this game though dude
damn
we do not fully understand all that is
the density but where are the aliens
to be unraveling this
mystery here on out to Captain I'm gonna
have a robot companion
proud to say no
another Bethesda game you'll love but
you won't finish I mean artifacts could
be everything we've been looking for the
main campaigns never take long to finish
the universe is asking us to unravel
[Music]
without the Galaxy could be at risk
it it do be looking sharp dude
if you didn't tell me that that was
Bethesda
I don't know that I would guess based on
the way that combat looks
which is awesome
forever
[Music]
it looks really good
This Is Where We Belong
[Music]
it's uh it's just so exciting when we
get a new Bethesda RPG because like no
matter what
I [__] love video games man September
6th let's go
um
I feel like like almost the whole
Gaming Community just [__] converges
on it like like Skyrim was such a big
deal when it came out you know
the download size is gonna be something
yeah
how many discs do this
and it's like the conversation around it
and I feel like the modders especially
with like help with this I have
historically supported modders like they
just
I don't know it's just like such a a
moment in gaming
um that we kind of have with like Zola
as well
especially now it's just the whole
Community gets together and is like oh
my [__] god this is so cool and I
feel like
Starfield will be that in it I love it
[Music]
sorry did I miss once you do this is
from
[Music]
don't not are you serious
it didn't say
[Music]
oh
don't know it's like really up to some
like
stupid different stuff for them I mean
they started with remember me I guess
and then went like life is strange which
is already very different
but they
how big is a team now
I feel like they're getting so creative
[Music]
yeah since uh
definitely a free climb game
which I don't know that we've seen that
much of there are like those challenge
ones um when you fall and die and that's
it this
looks cool
[Music]
juice sand
there's a democrine world premiere
thank you
[Music]
it's just Persona 5 again
no it's on the water
[Music]
okay
good variety this has been a great
conference in my opinion
[Music]
oil rig
survival horror is my guess
I'll take it
we get it play again day one with Game
Pass we get it
which is so funny because I think I was
like one of the first people I made a
YouTube video where I was like I just
need to rant about how impressive it is
that Xbox has these conferences where
all these things are coming in game
pause everybody shut up because I feel
like people didn't get it
yeah
gay boss is so good dude
but also it'd be better to just say it
like at the beginning or the end
well nah marketing teams nowadays
uh I feel like we've seen this before
[Music]
what if I go gets her own game
okay maybe not dungeons of hinterberg I
mean
not a lot of detail on that but that
does look like my type of game
hi
I'm very excited to be returning is
Johnny silver I played it yesterday
for cyberpunk 2077.
Phantom Liberty
this new adventure reunites Johnny and V
on a dangerous Street such a lovable man
as secret agent Solomon Reed I tried to
get to Idris in my playthrough but I
couldn't get this it's cool to be a part
of this game with you man hey and me and
Alana as a player on that too you'll get
to visit Dogtown an unexplored part of
19 and rescue the president of the new
United States just say something real
quick about Dogtown
so I got to see a little bit of Dogtown
the ball goes up for Phantom Liberty
um real quick before we continue
um
it was my first time ever playing
cyberpunk on console
and there are a couple things where like
the PC experience cyberpunk was always
beautiful I only ever played it on PC
you can still go see my launch day
streams on my channel the game always
ran quite well and looked very very good
that was the PC experience and while the
review scores were so high right
um
and then I saw a dog town and I played
it on Xbox and I was like man this is
ugly
because dogtown's supposed to be ugly
because it is also because it looks too
much like LA and I was like well I live
here and this place is ugly
why do I need to see it in a video game
this place is hideous [__] hell um
but also it's my first time actually
playing on a console
they didn't send me a cyberpunk PC they
did not get sent to a cyberpunk PC so no
it was just my own but I was like well I
guess they nailed it it's [__] ugly
and Dogtown is supposed to be that like
America culturally right expect a
massive expansion twists secrets and
plenty of stuff too but the story
content was really well paid you know
the team at CD project
they're raising the bar when it comes to
telling cinematic stories and video
games and I really can't wait for you to
play it on Xbox series X and S
but enough talking I just love it I'm
guessing you want to see for yourself
and so it is my honor and pleasure to
give you and introduce the official
trailer for Phantom Liberty
check it out
there's got to be a way out of this
Johnny
I'm dying
there's nothing can stop that
V it seems like a pretty big
expansion
so I did meat sauce
and I can save your life
what's the catch
I need you to get to Dogtown
attention all Dogtown residents
president managed to crash yeah play
through all this stuff too
man's got a thousand and one reasons to
want Myers as a hostage sleeper agents
time to wake them up
so nusa is tossing us back into The Fray
huh stay sharp we're in the Wolf's Den
now
yeah I like almost don't want to watch
this so time to eat back and I because
I'm definitely gonna play it I'm excited
about it it's the top I did this
yesterday too I think I maybe don't want
to look at it so I'm just going to not
watch
I'm good I don't need to see it I played
an hour of it yesterday
I don't want to have anything else
spoiled for me
so I'm just not gonna look at it just
not gonna look it's fine
I really do feel like the voice actors
who played B you know the treason ain't
everybody should have
um they don't want it wherever she goes
people get hurt it sucks that she got
dragged down with the cyberpunk stuff
they promised me
um take care I think she's so good
situations such a good performance one
of the best of the year like by a mile
and I don't I don't think she really got
the apple and she probably deserved that
take your truth be come on
not paying attention
the thing into it soon but I'm not going
to talk over it so you guys can still
watch it okay
[Music]
foreign
I played it I really enjoyed it
2013 kind of popping off
again
more Persona again
oh did I say 2014 I mean 20 23 sorry
[Music]
I didn't expect that to be even a
quarter of this much persona
not even a tiny
bit this much persona
unless it's not persona
it probably is
I feel like if they were announcing a
new persona they'd probably do it a bit
differently
[Music]
okay
I mean a lot of similarities
[Music]
of course
save more for um TGs
cool
again cool with it metaphor re fantasio
that is not a great name
World premiere some bad titles here to
be honest
[Music]
happy to see Atlas
World premiere from Xbox game studios
and creators of the Banos Banner Saga
Trilogy Humanities cities have fallen
is to seek Sanctuary here
in the belfry
you must explore this world
another Co-op to find the origins of
this evil
dungeon
type battle that and to bring the sick
back to our people or is it like a
another city
building
explore a co-op Adventure
[Music]
I like that style
I have a changing world like literally
life procedurally generated
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
yeah a lot of cell Shader games huh you
can save human bring it back
terrible and I wonder if that will be
like a city expansion
type thing as well
[Music]
not 33 players how dare you
premiere
[Music]
a lot of first party
oh in Exile okay
[Music]
I'm interested
this city is a miracle of progress
a finely tuned
delicately balanced machine
only time
[Music]
but it only takes one rebellious little
gear
to ruin
everything The Vibes are kind of
Dishonored Bioshock obviously
[Music]
if you alter our past
if you threaten what I have built
there is nowhere in space or time where
I will not do so it's like a it's a
timey why me more timey why me BioShock
Infinite type of thing
interesting
[Music]
oh no what did I do
that's cool for my friend puts one in
your scum
I wonder
Clockwork great name
qualcook Revolution is also a good name
I wonder
damn you
um how much control the player will have
over the tiny whiny stuff or is that all
scripted
that looks cool though
thank you all for joining us thanks Phil
today is a special day for me and the
team
I'm excited to see 11 games showcased
from our first party Studios we opened
with fables from playground games oh
yeah which will bring the franchise into
the modern era while staying true to its
British style and humor
compulsion and an exile shared their
first original experiences since joining
Xbox with south of midnight and
Clockwork Revolution
and we are thrilled at how a vowed is
shaping up for release next year from
the RPG Masters at obsidian
in addition to about our Studios will
deliver hellblade too and I want to play
virtually all of them is it weird that
gives me anxiety
with the time this month players can
look forward to Elder Scrolls online
necron and sea of Thieves Monkey Island
such a good idea as we look to Holiday
we will launch star field and Forza
Motorsport both built for Xbox series X
S and PC
we are also honored to share 14 games
today from our creative partners
like Star Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft
massive in collaboration with lucasfilm
games
33 Immortals that's awesome can't wait
to play that with chat that's gonna be
fun Goddess from Capcom incredible that
might have been my favorite to be honest
thanks to our continued parts
I'd also like to congratulate the studio
zero team on metaphor refanta Zeo it's
great fantasies next from the creators
of persona here in our show come on now
we are focused on putting our players
and game creators first in everything we
do
no matter if you choose to play on Xbox
PC or over the cloud all gamers are
welcome here at Xbox hey
when it comes to our consoles we have
heard your feedback on two fronts first
we have significantly increased our
supply of Xbox series you call this
making it easy I want new colors so bad
second come on I know you've wanted more
storage with Xbox series s and I'm
excited to share we have some news there
as well
colors please
okay I'll take a black series ass
note that I need more storage because I
just use the um
the Seagate for mine
oh look I'll take one more
[Music]
I love this series I travel with it it's
awesome
it's like so transportable
it's so cheap dude
rad
and now for the one more thing you've
all been waiting for
prepare for the most comprehensive Deep
dive okay I've ever done for the biggest
game we've ever built so I think this is
where I ended unfortunately everybody
because I have to go to the Final
Fantasy 16 event because I am hosting so
I'm going to stop here
um and then when I come back from Final
Fantasy 16 event
we will catch up on the Starfield Direct
which I'm really looking forward to I
have so many questions that I want
answered so I will stream that as well
I'll put this up on YouTube and then
Final Fantasy and then come back and do
this
um and throughout the week I'm hoping to
catch up on more of the conferences like
the PC gaming conference I really want
to watch the accessibility showcase
um the Volvo wholesome direct so I'll
find time throughout the week to catch
up on all of those it's just been very
busy because I've been having to go to
events and it's harder now I have a
full-time job so can only be Saturday
and Sunday
um but thank you all for hanging out and
I will be back later tonight to catch up
on stall field I'm very excited